good morning John it's Wednesday
September 24th and I think I owe
everyone an explanation
[Music]
so back you know ages ago I had this
idea that we would uh do this project in
which we would punish ourselves in
return for donations to Barack Obama's
campaign that was a good idea it was not
an achievable idea there was never any
way that we could give the nerdfighters
and eco geek and paper towns the
attention that all of those things
needed and through this new project at
the same time so we ended up not doing
that I guess what I'm trying to say is
that there are some things that you can
only say by referencing obscure absurd
10 year old viral videos like this one
[Music]
and this diamond interchange the
internet is so weird I actually found
the guy who wrote the original Hama song
if you know what I'm talking about I
like you if you don't Google llama song
and you will discover it cooking the top
one this happened when I was in college
and I was like ah
and I want the llamas on like 400 dimes
and I was singing the llama song of
myself the other day and I was like did
you see you well makuu's Obama oh no I'm
very much like to think the original
creator of the Obama song who I was able
to contact and ask his permission to do
that and he said as long as it is pro
Obama please do it he's British
I was in Canada the other day and
everyone I talked to was like can Obama
be our prime minister as well as your
president is that something we could
work out and I'm like no he's ours hmm
I'll put an mp3 in the sidebar if you
want to download that song song but it's
really not very good with the pictures
you gotta have the pictures so John and
I are working on the paper Tom's tour
dates and it's almost almost almost
finished thank God I am extraordinarily
excited about the reviews of Paper Towns
so very soon it sparks flop calm and
nerdfighters calm there will be a tour
list and you will be able to go and RSVP
for those events and that we really
awesome if you could RSVP for those
events but you don't need to talk about
that right now because not actually up
yet so why am i talking about it if you
don't want to talk about at all I'm Hank
and my brother is John and he writes
books and his new book is coming out
really soon and if you're watching this
and you're enjoying it that probably
means that you're a nerdfighter a
nerdfighter is a person who instead of
being made out of bones and organs and
stuff is actually made out of Awesome I
think you pretty much caught up now
dftba and if you want to make my brother
John a really really really happy person
and also read a really really really
good book you should go buy Paper Towns
it's not actually out yet but you could
pre-order it right now there is a link
in the sidebar to do that as well
surprise surprise if you do buy Paper
Towns I will give you a high five right
now that's all I've got to offer anyway
John and I are very much still paying
lots and lots of attention to the
presidential campaigns and generally
actually both participating a new
project called why a for Obama and
there's a bunch of authors who write for
younger people and you know
Oh everyone else writing about why they
care and why they're voting for Barack
Obama people included are like John
Maureen Johnson like Judy Blume Judy
freakin blue the Bob Rae Cory Doctorow
I love Cory Doctorow don't actually have
the first asset that won't live on the
site and its really awesome if you go
and read that essay you'll see a whole
new side of John that you never really
discusses here on YouTube check it out
and there's a link as you may have
guessed to that in the sidebar as well
question of the day what's your favorite
viral video I think mine is probably all
your base are belong to us and for those
of you who are too old or too young to
know what all your base are belong to us
is just Google that so that's my
favorite viral video what's your
favorite viral video